Rip it.
No intro.
We're just, we're here.
Hello.
Miku Tomato Doki here.
The Doki verse is truly expanding.
Oh my god, Doki, is that you?
I would like to be called Miku Doki, please.
Whoever wins gets Miku Atsune.
Little did they know, they get me.
What an honor.
They'll do the nail.
They actually get me, which I would think is the ultimate
Miku.
A Miku bird.
Yes, it's me.
Miku bird.
Yeah, not the Miku cup.
All right.
So we're in a little bit of a predicament because my manager
messaged me and was like, I don't think you're going to be
able to watch the full foot.
final by the way since there is a 30 minute halftime break
and I'm like all caps are you serious why is there a fucking
halftime show in football those guys are going to be so worn
down like they got to warm up all over again what the fuck
are they going to be doing 30 minutes like fucking playing
footsies in the fucking locker room like
yeah i was just like also i don't have the time to watch a
two plus hour game like i if i have to leave at 2 30 i i
have to leave at exactly 2 30 they can't do this to me they
they stay warm up trust oh my god i'm like are you Are you
fucking kidding me?
They're gonna have a fuck.
I'm not here for like whoever's...
I'm sorry, Madonna.
Like, they're not here for you.
Like, I hope they...
I hope you paid them to perform in this halftime show.
Because there's no way...
They don't need you.
I'm sorry, Madonna.
Like, if anything, you're getting publicity.
I don't know who's gonna be in the halftime show.
I just...
spad a random singer out.
Oh, sorry.
I did not mean, sorry.
I had it flipped during the France game because I joked
about it.
And because, you know, when you flip the French, oh, during
the England, I flipped England's flag as a joke.
Because when you flip England's flag, you can't tell if it's
flipped or not.
Like, that was an accident.
to unflip it all right i'm gonna be working while we watch
because like i don't know the world cup really fucking hates
me or something oh hey germany colombia and guitar as the
var people i wonder if this guy third guy gets a chair all
right like everything is scheduled when I'm the most busy.
Oh, hey, there's Mark Cucarella.
He says his signature move.
Distraction.
Oh, you can't see me.
My hair's in your face.
Yeah, so I have, like, a million things.
I have, like, for the announcement, because Mousy's sick
right now.
I don't know if she's still sick.
But because she's sick, I had to take the lead on everything
for the announcement.
So I'm all over the place because I still need to, like,
prep um prep the room and everything so so i'll be working
while um while while we watch uh well with the 30 minute
fucking half time i would have so much time to work i i need
to ask uh
uh uh
sorry i have i uh
All right.
All
right.
Here we go.
Sorry.
What am I watching?
Is this WWE?
Like...
Let's get ready to rumble!
Yeah, I feel like...
All right.
I'm ready for the timer.
I'm sorry.
I'm all over the place.
But at least we're watching some good.
football, right?
Right?
Well, this is a New York city, too.
Traffic must be absolutely fucking terrible.
Yeah.
I was gonna say, I was gonna say, it feels like I'm watching
a boxing match slash wrestling match with that announcing.
oh is it in new jersey is it not in new york oh new jersey
traffic is still gonna be fucking not as terrible but still
terrible yeah oh so it's actually worse can confirm traffic
sucks more than new york city really yeah this time you guys
are not ahead of me that's right i'm i'm I'm literally at
the stadium right now streaming.
I paid $30,000 to pay it.
Honestly, I will not be surprised.
I wonder, like, how much speed pays for his tickets.
Already?
He...
What?
The first...
Oh, he's smiling.
He's like, yeah, yeah, yeah, guys.
Oh, shit, okay, yeah.
All right, bro.
Bro, you're...
Bro, the bro code.
You're not supposed to smack a bro's code.
There's code.
You get it?
Because there's code started in the balls.
Bro, that bro broke the bro code.
Is she muted?
I don't think.
I think someone has the stream muted.
Come on, start murdering each other.
It's the finals.
I swear to God, if I have to watch, if I see at least...
If I...
Get a stopwatch, I see 30 minutes of Haramba.
I swear to God.
I don't know.
Don't make me do it.
You don't want to know what happens if I see 30 minutes of
Haramba.
I can't believe it.
The last game of World Cup.
My football arc is coming to an end today, guys.
Your favorite sports comment.
is gonna be semi-retired until the until the next four years
what would you do guys what were your favorite sport what
would you do when your sports commentator decides to be a
variety streamer after what the fuck was that pass no no
olympics i don't know i like i i don't know ever since no
olympic has had the same rush to me since um china and
england hosted i know like america what the fuck happened
over there like there was no bomb like this was just like a
little b it's like the b a little b plot over there there is
the women's world cup next year and then thank you the super
chat thank you thank you yeah they were they got inspired by
the w by the boxer announcer yeah there was like yeah i feel
like ever since like england uh well england because they
followed up with china's opening ceremony i don't know i
feel like opening ceremony what the fuck oh god that would
have been crazy that actually would have been a crazy shot
imagine it is like there was another guy there
but like ever since china and england's opening ceremony um
i i don't know i feel like i got holy shit another what was
that i know you baby but come on bro are you oh that was
fucking that okay he did a u.s right there like what that
little like love tap on the ball like bro where is the
fucking power in those legs you're you're like what he's
like 17 or eight i don't know i keep forgetting his age
there's too many young players um like 19 right he's 19
right bro like i know your legs are still growing you have
that 19 year old energy that you have you have three
girlfriends bro come on we know you got the energy
he's a growing boy
We know you haven't to keep up with three fucking girls
Bro's got this just three I won't be surprised if you picked
up a fourth in America
The colonizer versus the colonized This is the match of the
century The Spanish Inquisition There I don't know the setup
was so good and then he like fumbles it.
Whoa!
What the fuck?
He's like pushing him!
What?
Bro, it's like rocking the boat.
What in my...
Okay.
That's insane.
Bro, that guy was actually like rocking the boat.
Like, you saw that, right?
He's just like, whoa, whoa, it's an earthquake.
The bone is shaking while you're fucking dribbling.
Yeah, but then he's so lucky.
The guy that was pushing was so lucky that the guy fell
after passing.
Because that would have been a foul.
Because you're not supposed to push hard enough for them to
fall.
Oh, that was a good seal.
That was...
Oh!
Oh, there's three people on this guy.
No, that got pushed with his hands.
I literally saw him.
That keeper is fucking wild for doing that.
He's like, like, what is that?
What was that?
That's just the freaking love tap.
He's just like, do I pass?
It's like, he was trying to do a 50-50.
I was like, do I pass or shoot?
I should pass.
Oh, that's a bad pass.
luckily luckily guys the u.
the u.s is not in the finals
imagine if it was like u.s in the finals and then it cut to
that clip imagine all the tweets we'll get from that guys
I was just like, who is that?
Why did we cut to that?
Is that not the FIFA president?
Imagine the tweets we gave.
US was the finals match, and that was the shot they cut to
next.
Vokey, they're playing super aggressive right now.
Oh, my God.
This is a hot potato action.
Oh, nice deal.
Nice deal.
Oh, my head.
The stadium.
The stadium is so loud right now.
I can't imagine, like, how fucking loud it is, like, in
person.
I do wonder.
I think it's more Argentina fans in the stadium than there
are Spain fans.
Oh, yeah, definitely.
It just panned to, like, all blue.
It just panned to the back, and it's just blue.
blue just a little sprinkle of red
you can find like it's like where's waldo you can find the
which who are the spanish fans yeah oops all blue i do think
i do think that having home advantage is more pressure
though i am oh there's more pressure rack racked up if
you're playing Like, with more, um, it would have a home
advantage.
Oh!
He's like, yonk!
Because you don't want to disappoint your fans, but then
there's so much pressure.
It's a little fucking block there.
You know what I'm surprised of?
The lack of fouls right now.
I mean, at this point, getting a...
Oh, that's cute.
Look at his shoes.
It's yellow and red.
Pass it to the hair guy.
He'll distract him with his fabulous hair.
Well, today we're going to find out the Miku curse is real.
I think the Miku curse is stronger than all the other curses
out there.
Just because, like, the Miku curse has yet to fail and the
fact that every team that's Miku to what lost lost to one so
be interesting this would be the deciding game
the fact that every team lost to one is crazy Essie is
special Essie got one team wrong Miku has it Miku Miku has
not got it got wrong yet and also predicted the score oh
shit what happened all right oh okay but oh okay i wouldn't
think it like hurt oh maybe it did hurt that but all right
let's see
oh he's like come on bro i can't can't even stand stands up
come on then it hurts so bad oh what the fuck Will Farrell
what the fuck um Farrell sorry I have to sing that song Will
Farrell and and happy guy from Despicable Me
The Pharaoh Williams.
Damn.
I don't know.
They paid more than...
They paid more than 30k to be there.
Will Pharaoh the Pharaoh.
Pharaoh Williams.
Oh!
I mean, it's nice that he, like, picked them up.
Oh, shit!
I would put you to retirement home!
What the fuck?
He's like, I'm going to make sure this is your last World
Cup.
That's like crazy.
Between two barrels.
You can't help, but check.
The future is now, old man.
Target down.
That's insane.
No yellow card, too.
Oh, too, too far.
Yeah, Messi needs to score, like, three goals, right?
To take over.
What happens if they're tied?
Did they get two golden boots?
Oh, my God.
Oh, that was a good pass.
That was a good...
Oh!
Two and assist.
Okay.
I swear to God, I'm going to be...
I feel like I might not be...
able to watch this last um won't be able to watch like the
the finals at the until the end like it's like everyone knew
everyone knew i every important thing i have to do this week
i feel like
i know it's such bad timing too for me like the outfit debut
and then i had my special announcement and everything oh it
was bro how oh what the fuck am i watching wrestling what
round three round
round one nothing happens around they're like wait a minute
we can still push we can keep pushing guys they're not
calling anything round two oh yeah if i go down you're
coming down with me now that's a word murder ball
New Jersey is a PvP Welcome to New Jersey They just have the
New Jersey spirit That's insane That was three rounds of
tackles Have you ever played it football with your life on
the line?
No yellow card yet though
And no yellow card
What?
He's like Rev!
Did you just see that rough all right what happened i didn't
see it though what bro okay come all right oh come bro bro
okay good acting class is paid up acting good good acting
guys and good act mad is that mad daemon is it
That's Oscar level acting, pants to Matt Damon, and scene.
The fact that, like, yeah, oh, Matt, he's just like, the
Odyssey can wait.
I was like, Matt Damon.
I liked how they're like, really good acting, pants to Matt
Damon.
Like, Matt Damon approves.
like holy the fact that the other like his teammate was like
ref did you see that that was a oh my god ref did you see
that he was clearly he like punched him he got a knife and
started stabbing my teammate and then plays replay oh is it
his wife is from argentina oh i did not know that
i did not realize during the boat ride in the odyssey that
he fucking sails to new jersey wherever he has a gun
Matt Damon is here to present the best acting award in FIFA
that's why it was such a long journey I love all the Odyssey
memes they're all so funny I think my favorite one was the
was you know how like people are like you have to watch the
film in IMAX because it's um oh oh oh he couldn't grab the
pass you didn't stabilize it Offside
I love all the Odyssey memes
What was up there was apparently a movie competing with the
Odyssey right now And there's like zero tickets be Oh Moana
I don't know like when will Disney like stop Like I don't
understand there's no way the live action Live action films
are making that much money There is no fucking way Like I
refuse to believe all that like the live action films are
profitable all right not gonna lie guys I don't know why but
is it me or does this game feel slow like there is
aggression but also it feels very like slowish I don't know
if that's just me
does it does it feel a little slow
yeah i looked at the timer and i was like it's only been 22
minutes i was like yeah
yeah maybe i got like a two adjusted with the france versus
england yeah after the match yesterday anything feels slow i
was like it's only been 22 minutes i felt like
yeah everyone i'm like you don't need to save energy you
literally have 30 minutes of halftime.
If anything, it's just you're fucking resetting.
Oh.
Oh, it's Spain's ball.
What was it called for?
What was the foul?
Oh, yeah.
Two hands.
Yeah.
I was like, but nobody fell.
A foul card without anyone falling?
What is this?
And I've never, I've never seen this before.
Like,
oh my god.
Nobody falling?
Is someone getting fouled?
This is a new thing.
I think this is the first in World Cup history.
Like, that sounds fake.
Fake football.
All right, back to work time.
All right, I need to download some stuff for it.
Wait a minute.
speed performs his way i show speed was performing oh they
didn't out there was a closing ceremony they invited speed
to perform at the fucking what
there was a fucking a closing ceremony
yeah bro i show speed fucking performed at the closing
ceremony but it was an opener yeah today i can't link it
because it's on tsn you can only see if you're a canadian
it's all my canadian goons today's your special day you get
to see this canadian exclusive tweet yeah how did they close
before it finished that's what i'm saying is the closing
ceremony not supposed to be like closing
that's crazy
well i mean good for him though good for him i feel like
speed has has the most comeback energy like arc ever out of
a lot all the streamers out there wait post malone and we're
gonna have another half-time show after this they perform
sunda Flower?
Oh, so here's another canned exclusive tweet.
Apparently they perform Sunflower, too.
Like, but then we have an opening ceremony.
Then we have, like, a halftime show after.
Like,
we have, like, a halftime show, right?
Oh, my God.
Bruno Mars?
Bro, everybody's here.
Who's this guy?
Wait.
the piano man the guy that is always depressed in all his
movies oh my god everybody's here yeah it's like why why do
we have all these what's the point of having a closing
ceremony before the bat before the game ends and then like
and also a half-time show yeah adrian brody yeah he always
he's always he's always depressed man like in every movie
he's in he's like Like, like, it's actually, like, trauma,
traumatic trauma shit.
Yeah, everyone is here.
It's, like, the Smash Bros.
Like, like, who are they gonna get?
Like, they already got, like, fucking, I get, I got, they
got, like, post Malone.
I guess post Malone isn't a halftime material.
Like, that's what I'm saying.
I'm saying, like, these, it's already gonna be a full,
nobody's watching this for the halftime show.
Like, like...
I don't think they realize this is this like even though
this is in America, I bet you 80% of those seats, the seat
people in those seats right now are not American.
Like I do not think they're here for celebrity.
I think they're just here for football.
if anything majority of the americans that are watching this
game at the stadium are in the celebrity box like yeah and
that's just like what's the point like i the celebrity the
people singing at the halftime show they better be paying
the fifa to perform and not fifa paying them Like they like
I did they they they get so much more publicity performing
here Because like the Super Bowl is like primarily American
but the World Cup is like global So like they'll have they
get much more publicity from doing a From performing in the
World Cup than they do in a Super Bowl
Madonna Shakira BTS and Justin Bieber Damn.
Nobody's.
I'm sorry, but...
I'm...
Okay, that...
The Muppets are there?
Okay, it was worth it.
It's all worth it.
You should have started with that.
Well, how old is Madonna now?
Okay, now maybe the halftime show can be saved.
Okay, maybe it's worth it now.
Yeah.
The Muppets are there.
Oh my god, is she actually 67?
Is she actually?
I thought she was older.
Not gonna lie.
Of course.
It's the Muppets.
I thought she was older.
I thought she was a lot older.
I legitimately.
Like, I don't know.
With all that makeup and plastic surgery.
And very young men.
Come on, Cucarella.
Use your hair.
Bro, like, how are you going to pass that?
There's, like, 20 men in front of you.
Just start whipping.
Whipping them with their hair.
When do they start alting, guys?
When?
Where do I see my alt?
By this point, England would have scored twice.
You're already saving alt for World Cup 2, guys?
There is no rule against whipping your hair.
Oh, no.
Oh, yeah.
No, that's a...
Yeah.
Bro, yank that man down.
The guy with his phone?
He's like, don't worry.
I'll have the perfect shot.
Like, he brings out the phone next to the $1,000 camera.
Like, I...
even bring a camera i mean i guess like his phone would work
that's crazy oh
is it whoops
i didn't even notice it's so far out there it blended in
this match is pretty tense it's tense but slow like it
doesn't like the fact that it's only been 34 minutes too oh
my god that pass was
beautiful pass, but then it was off-side.
That was actually insane.
Between the legs?
That shit is so hard to do.
Yeah, they're edging.
Like, oh my god!
That is such a beautiful pass.
That is so hard to do.
I want to see the VARS scan.
How off-side was it?
Was it pee-pee offside or what oh that was smart bro it's
like past team versus passing team
or it's a big toe offside oh whoa whoa whoa whoa
offside is basically a role where you can't spawn camp the
goalkeeper so you have to be at like a certain distance away
from the goalie uh during certain like play like shots
because so then you can't spawn camp him it's sort of hard
to see when it's offside like when you're watching the game
itself
yeah be behind the defender
he acts like football in gaming turns
I don't know people were joking yesterday but this is it's
just because like every mistake counts so every both teams
are playing like super carefully but the France versus
England game was just stat padding is because like
technically they have nothing to lose and like teams tend to
like not care about bronze matches so it's like more like an
exhibition match so it was literally just people like either
giving the b team more play time or like just to pad your
stats so like that's why like like even like england subbed
in their goalkeeper even though they never subbed him out
before yeah they're they're doing they're doing right now
they're playing eco
yeah because like originally they were not they were
planning on like subbing out Mbappe, but Mbappe wanted more
goals, so that's why he was playing on, he was playing.
Yeah, so this is an eco match.
Yeah, like, normally, yeah, they were just playing the, just
fuck around, like, the third place game.
But, like, this one, everyone has to be, like, super
careful, and just take shots that they think they can, like,
get 100% guaranteed.
That's why it feels so slow.
Oh!
That was a good save, though.
That was a good save.
That was insane.
The setup?
Oh my god, that was a...
That was such a good setup, too.
Like, oh, but if they...
Oh, but, like, it fucked up.
And the pass was beautiful, but then they couldn't score.
Who do I want to win?
I don't know.
I'm Miku I'm Miku
Okay Miku I want Miku to win I'm Miku buried
Canada Canada fucking comes in the field It starts rushing
down.
Like, they're like, the entire Argentina team just got hit
by the Diary of Parasite.
Well, who would play for them now?
And then Kata comes in, don't worry.
I'll be the hero for Argentina.
Kata comes in in the steel chair.
Yellow card.
But then it was Kano all along that gave them all lettuce
And here comes Kano's steel chair Did he just kick him
after?
Wait, what did he see?
Oh, I couldn't see.
I was like, did the guy just kick them after he fell down?
That's crazy.
wait a second gotta double tap bro yeah make sure he stays
down
Argentina gained the first yellow card minus 10k I mean
already the second like whoever even the first or second
place the prize winning from first and second place like
already pays off for every yellow card they got
What the fuck are these passes, guys?
They get, like, insane passes and then, like, choke it in
the end.
Yeah, who was he passing to?
The Invisible 12th member?
Invisible man?
The Invisible man is taking off?
Oh, that would have been insane pass if that worked.
Cucurella!
Oh, there you go.
Goodbye, Cucurella.
I thought he would do something, I guess.
I thought Mr. Cucurella would, like, do something.
Oh, I mean, that was ambitious.
That was very ambitious.
Like, like, oh, oh, he wouldn't have been able to save it if
he actually... That's crazy.
Oh, the goalie would not have been able to save it in that
angle.
He actually, if it hits the corner right there, if it wasn't
so wide, it hits the wind.
Quick, sealed the stadium.
Oh, wait, how did he got injured?
What happened there?
What he has to come off?
Like, nothing happened.
god he has not been subbed out before like turn on the ac i
drove the replay what the fuck happened to him like nobody
was on this guy
okay oh it probably was the win guys you don't understand
the wind is going mock seven right now only a professional
athlete can play against this wind did he eat the lettuce
guys maybe just what if you just want a shit like what do
you do at that point like you're playing the game and you're
like oh fuck what if you just really need to use the
bathroom like what do we do like
who's this guy i've recognized every celebrity but him
the grass is right i would assume like they just don't eat
any they like right before right before the game they just
oh my god this goalkeeper is crazy for only four minutes i
would thought it would be longer oh my god get ready for the
30 minute half time show that's wembley who's wembley oh
it's an nba player Yeah, I don't know ball.
I'm not even gonna pretend I know ball.
Yo, I placed a 3K better, Argentina.
Wish me luck, Noah.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh, I think I didn't receive it, though.
Are you sure you placed the correct place at a correct
place?
Guys, I don't think I got you to the 3K.
You might have to place the bed again on this channel.
Yeah, I don't see you in my books.
Are you sure?
I mean, you still have enough time to place it.
There's still enough time.
You're not in my books at the moment, though, Noah.
Are you sure?
Are you...
Oh, old.
Well, they have to stall time now.
It's like 30 more minutes still than...
Honestly, because it's a 30-minute halftime show, most
likely it'd be like 40 minutes.
Oh, my God.
I have to leave at 2.30, guys.
I love you to play some bed on Spain.
I sped on Spain.
No, I got you.
I got you down.
No, thank you to Super Chat.
Thank you.
I have to leave at 2.30, no matter what, guys.
I'm sorry.
So that...
Like, if the game does go overtime, Like there's nothing I
could do.
I would say if I could but I have obligations like I if I I
VOD halftime show That sucks though, you know because it's
like the entire football arc You know, I've been here for
like half the football arc and I got ended with me just
fucking not finishing the game if if it does go super over
time Only if it goes super over, Tab.
But it's been a fun arc, though.
I've been enjoying it a lot.
I'm just watching them pass for 80 years.
Alright.
I'm ready for Madonna.
I'm thinking ready for Madonna.
Like, Madonna beats...
Like, one...
It's a wide five people.
Why do we need so many people for this halftime show?
What was it?
Madonna, Shakira, BTS, and Justin Bieber?
Sorry, four people.
All right, wheeler out right now, guys.
I don't have much time.
Just...
Like, who requested this?
Who asked for this?
You can't bring more people to the stadium.
Yeah, apparently BTS is...
there too
like i guess they want like the zoomer like oh wait not
zoomer because like they've been around for a while they
want the k-pop uh girls the k-pop status to watch too but
like they're not gonna watch after the the perform imagine
they're actually no they would be like watching at the But
then I'm like, do they even like Like We're able to get
tickets before The football fans though You know what's
scarier than a K-pop Stand?
A football fan Because like You say K-pop stands, they're
like Like on Like they're like Online They have a lot of
like they have a lot of presence But football fans have
presents online and offline as in like they can punch you
they they can start riots yeah dpop doesn't have hooligans
exactly yeah just bought dragoon slippers yeah football fans
you have to worry about them even when you touch grass They
will fight the police.
Well, football fans, they will...
They will also...
They're also scary online as well.
See you.
Football fans are a lot crazier online.
Like the most extreme ones.
And offline.
It's like they got the best of both worlds.
I won't say best.
They got the worst of both worlds.
like like
football fans will not hesitate to go full gamer well she
think of a super chat they could thank you oh shit 65
percent percent wait they haven't oh that's true i just
noticed rt has not shot shot the goal yet it's always been
spain it's okay in the last 20 minutes that's when they they
activate their alt guys if you read the patch notes
argentina will alt in the in the last 20 minutes uh just
bought dry gold slippers buy toky merch yeah did you have to
confirm my bank it's a legit purchase international sales
for the way by the way you know super chat they get the oh
yeah i should let's see you all right let me i forgot about
that master shiller doesn't shill but yes merch is out right
now the merch put it right here uh close by thank you super
chat thank you thank you what's worse a philadelphia eagles
fans or thank you for the super chat thank you thank you uh
solid thank you super chat thank you thank you grandparents
survived the football war actual event other factors
influence it they're wild it can get very oh yeah yeah like
football has started a war i don't think kpop has started a
war yet
Thank you, Mr. Super Chat.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Yeah, the passive buff.
Oh, true.
And, and football fans are drinking while they're rioting.
All right, let me dial it work stuff while we wait for
the...
While we wait for the halftime.
Let me make sure everything is...
I don't want to accidentally, like, play anything.
I'm going to download stuff for the announcement.
All right.
And
then...
Sorry, I'm working now.
I'll focus back when...
I guess...
I don't even know.
I guess, like, after Madonna.
It's like putting my Spotify playlist on.
What are you...
What are
you...
Let's see.
No, isn't Madonna first?
It's been a fun...
It's been a really fun football arc.
I've been...
You know, this is the first time I've done something like
this.
So thank you guys for joining the ride and letting me have
have my little football takeover uh last month with no
gaming for we haven't really gamed in a while also next week
next or technically it's this week this week i have a rivals
tournament just so you guys i have a rival's tournament too
this week as well uh so i've been a very very busy tomato
very busy bird yeah we put a lot of video games on hold
because but we'll be back to normal we'll be back to normal
after this but thank you guys for hanging out with me during
the football because I feel like I won't have time to say
this so we'll just do it on half during the half we had 30
minutes of halftime like maybe 40 so like I'm gonna do this
now I'm gonna do this now because I feel like at 2 30 I just
leave like because if i'm sad if they do go to penalties and
i can't watch like watch it with you guys but i do have
other obligations and it was just unfortunate that it it
overlapped with each other uh bird thank you for the super
chat thank you thank you uh no dragon can be an eagles fan
also the footballer is way more complicated than what the
nickname for it tells thank you for super chat thank you
thank you but um it's been a wild ride and thank you all for
joining me on my football journey uh and i'm glad you guys
were have been enjoying my commentary i've never done this
before i've never like commented on uh football before so
i'm glad you guys are having fun with it i don't know what
the fuck i'm saying i'm just saying anything that come like
that's just in my mind oh my god is that madonna is that
what is going what What the...
What is going on?
Is this the...
Is this the halftime show?
Who are the people beside it?
The people out there do not...
I'm sorry, but the people behind...
What?
Ah!
Save!
Half-time save!
Ah!
Oh
Yeah Oh, oh, oh my God, it's row.
Oh my God the puppet row favor system doll I mean, it's a
good song.
Oh, yeah, no, definitely some K-pop stands are in there.
Are in the stadium.
I wonder if some of them, like, bought it for BTS.
And it's 400 song.
This is a good song, though.
I like his song.
Yeah, they're back.
And then, then, mom.
Yeah, bomb, bomb.
And this is, like, the most popular america like song in
america from bts i want the muppets to sing with them when
will i have the muppets slash bts collab
It reminds me of SodaPop.
Yeah, I think SodaPop was inspired by this.
Yeah, give Miss Piggy the mic!
I want to hear it sing Dynamite!
The camera work is insane, though.
Because it doesn't feel like a live show.
Like, it feels like...
It feels like this was a pre-recorded slash music video in
terms of, like, cinematography.
But the camera work is actually really...
good like it feels like I'm watching a music video Ted Lasso
like it feels like an ad you know not like I didn't realize
that it was a halftime show cuz it looks like yeah oh my god
Ted Lasso I loved you and Saturday Night Live oh
my god
Oh, there's a lot of believers out there.
Sing baby!
He can't sing his old catalog, by the way, because he sold
it.
So he has to sing his new songs.
He is very talented, though.
It really sucks at how, like, all the stuff he's went
through.
Because he's a very, very talented.
It's like his voice is so buttery.
Well, the thing is, like, all his new songs are very slow.
So it would have been nice if like, yeah, he went through a
lot of shit.
It would have been nice if it like followed up with it
because it was like the high and then the slow now.
But like he can't sing any of his old songs because he sold
it.
It would have been nice if it was it kept the high or you
know, now I'm like now I'm warmed down.
Yeah, now I'm tired.
Now I'm EP, Justin.
Justin, I'm EP now.
Sing baby.
The song is...
It's just his newer stuff is not the best.
Because he's, like, more depressed now.
Like, actually, no.
Yeah.
Actually, I can't tell.
I think he's more, like, traumatized now.
So his songs are more slow.
Oh, shit.
Shakira.
No, not the new one.
Bring me the old...
I want the older World Cup song.
Waka, waka, waka.
How old is Shakira?
She's like 40, right?
She looks so good for 40.
She has several kids.
She's 57?
she looks really good for 50 the fact that like her hips
hasn't given out yet for 57 oh almost okay she's 50 okay the
fact that like her hips has not given out for 50 is crazy
that like bro those are the strongest hips in the world
yeah her hips don't lie yeah they sing walk a walk a Shakira
Did they all just get one sign?
Oh, that's cute.
Love.
Wait, who's this kid?
Yes!
Oh my god, it's the count!
What's the what's the fucking count doing here?
That's Bro, you're not- go back to Sesame Street, bro.
Who invited this guy?
Wait, cookie monster?
Oh, yeah, the speaking curb hit her back together now.
You know, they, like, broke up at one point.
He's here to count the goals.
One, two, yellow card.
Ah, ah, ah.
uh i can't believe it oh voodoo zealous you know that's
illegal to bring to the stadium like hello the rules for me
but not for me wait that's not fair why can they bring the
voodoo zealous i looked that up you're not allowed to bring
like any horns or like they specifically said like
stadium i don't know like why i like how cookie monster elmo
and like the count is so it's such a i guess he's counting
the goals but he's so it's so random like elmo i get it
like i get it elmo i get it but like the count
it was short everyone just had one song that's what i'm
saying like just have one like one or two musicians but like
everyone just had one song like even bts was like the
condensed version of dynamite oh who's one yellow card two
yellow card ah uh let's see all right back to work uh oh i
need to fill this the sheet for rivals let's see all right
guys back to work time until like they get the players back
in uh i
don't even know if i might can i stream this on youtube was
my current rank
competitive achievements none
i want to be two prayer rivals
i don't what is i don't know what do i write there the truth
and competitive like in rivals like i'm not a pro like
why should a captain draft you I play support
yeah why should I have 912 I have 912,000 subscribers that's
why you should draft me
okay I need to mute this too many people are talking in this
channel all
right let's see why should i i don't know why should a
captain draft me i don't know um i know ball
i know ball just write that i know ball
I've been watching a World Cup instead of instead of playing
rivals.
No, I'm just right.
I know ball.
She knows ball.
All right.
There you are submit I submitted my draft compelling
argument.
She knows a ball.
All right, I'm gonna just I'm gonna take my own bathroom
break.
I'll be right back up.
guys
came back in time they better someone better score i can't
watch if they go overtime it's really bad for me i better
see some fucking goals
oh shit let's see uh oh
all right let me and And it downloads some stuff for it
later today.
The
sidebar.
Yeah, there's no goals so far.
I'm just zoning out right now until like something.
Like, I don't know.
They're just jamming out right now.
I'm just vibing Let's have so much stuff to do Oh there's
the water boy
Alright here we go We're time to play some fucking ball Well
Why do they never like Give me a countdown Hello?
Do they know I'm watching?
All right, they're two seconds ahead.
I cannot be.
All right, there you go.
Oh, they're more aggressive now.
Yeah, second half now.
Why didn't he...
Oh, Yemelle's mad.
Did you see that?
Yemelle's like, I was so open!
Oh, Yemelle's mad.
He was.
He was open.
Uh.
You should have fucking passed that.
Yemelle had a perfect pass there.
Oh, no.
Passed it back.
Who's Simon?
Or Simone?
Oh, is that?
Oh, they're talking about like, they're like, there's
Simone.
I was like, why are they showing this one guy?
They're talking about the position.
oh yeah but he hit the ball wait what was it a foul or not I
didn't hear a whistle yeah he hit the ball like that's yeah
so it should not be a foul
oh corner kick there he is there's Messi oh is that whose
ball is it go to your corner get It's golden because you're
all leaving this You're all leaving now
It's alright guys in the last 20 minutes I'm waiting for the
last We gotta go through the slop to get to the last 20
minutes Then they'll start alting They're just building all
charge Oh yeah my anniversary plush is still available Yeah
Another sub
Yeah, shaders are still compiling.
It's like those in like CS, there's like the little 1v1
rounds.
Oh, Hadba!
Hadba!
Imagine if you got called for Hadba.
It's the warm-up round, guys.
It's knife round.
Come on, do something.
please start murdering oh what
what the fuck did you hear that that was a pharaoh scream
okay okay okay okay
oh i i almost believed it i all the gym that was i I almost
believed it, too.
And the Oscar.
Okay.
Alright.
Bro, I thought that man was actually getting stabbed.
The guy screamed like he was gonna fucking die.
But why isn't he in the Odyssey?
Yeah.
Oh, shit.
What's going on?
There's like, this is a man.
Okay, that's a yellow card.
That should be a...
What?
That man pushed the guy over the guy that's knocked down.
No, that should be a yellow.
That guy should get a yellow.
That's what the fuck?
Like, that guy actually pushed the man like over the other
guy.
He didn't even get a yellow.
Oh, now he does.
Wait, they're giving the Spanish guy the yellow?
Oh no, yeah, no, yeah, no, he, no, that, bro, and then he
chest, holy shit, and then he chest bumps the, he like,
puts, he does, he's like, keep pushing it, yeah, it should
at least be a, yellow, yeah, yeah, but the, he, the fact
that he, like, like, even if the guy was acting on the
ground, he, like, antagonized it further,
like, Even if the guy, like, what's it called?
When they fake the fall.
What's the word for it?
Not act, no, there's a dive.
Yeah, even the guy was diving.
The guy, like, that player, like, shoved a random Spanish
player for no reason.
Like, just because, like, I don't know.
Like, you should have just knelt down and shoved the guy on
the floor.
And just start like pushing him on the floor.
Like that's the guy that's already on the floor.
You didn't have to shove the random Spanish guy that had
nothing to do with it.
If he's angry just kneel down and just shove the guy that's
already on the floor.
Holy shit.
Yeah and from the ref too.
Like if he was more calm about it.
way yeah they're just like why fuck me for the guy that got
shoved he's just like what the fuck fuck me for I was just
trying to help I was just trying to cross back to my team
holy shit now it's crazy
oh the defense right Argentina is really good right now.
Even with Spain having majority of possession.
I feel like I haven't seen Argentina shot the ball yet.
But don't worry.
Last 20 minutes, guys.
Last 20 minutes.
Oh, good pass.
Good pass.
You wanted to pass Argentina, right?
Another one?
What the fuck?
Will someone give these guys like bulletproof vests or some
shit?
okay replay on the scoring not how the guy fucking collapsed
like how did he fall oh that was insane i don't know through
the legs always like very very cool to see
oh oh my god all these beautiful passes but like no
follow-up.
Cucarela's just like, it's okay, bro.
It's okay.
Oh, corner kick.
Are you guys ahead of me?
No, I can't fast forward anymore.
This is as fast as it gets.
Oh, I'm ahead.
It's because I'm literally in the stadium right now.
Um, yeah.
You know, I know who i am i'm miku bird i get all the vip
privileges yeah they're gonna start pat they're gonna cut
the feet to me after i'm
gonna add 10 seconds to you i'm literally playing right now
i'm literally the ref like
the little camera drone above them so the ball hits the
camera you'll actually see it this time
United States of America bought an ad just to advertise the
United States of America?
Yeah.
Imagine if the U.S.
has bought an ad space just for it to say United States of
America.
I believe it.
We got it.
We got to advertise America.
I like how it's like USA next to Coca-Cola.
Another?
A free kick?
They gotta outact the Spaniards.
Who has the best soap opera?
The Spanish or the Argentinians?
Francis, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Venmo, thank you for the super chat.
Let's go, America.
Which one's a...
Spain?
Oh, that's why.
Spain easy.
They have the more acting experience.
Yeah, who has the better telenovas?
Telenovelas.
So telenovelas.
Oh, it's snowing.
Oh, he started spraying the players.
Like, like a cat.
It's like, bad, bad players.
Telenovelas.
It started snowing.
My casters were just like, it started snowing.
Oh.
Oh, he got it out of the corner.
Oh, wait.
Who touched it?
Oh, the Spaniard touched it.
You touched it at the very end, too.
Oh, little dance.
No.
Mom, mom, mom.
one one one please please just one goal just one goal
whichever side please so i can at least watch till the end
that's it please i just just let me watch till the very end
that's all i want yeah a little dance break
i just i just want to be there till the end
One measly goal, sir.
And have some more.
There's still an hour left.
I don't have an hour.
I have to leave at 2.30.
Guys, if we go to penalties, I have to leave.
We won't even get to see it to the end.
I have to leave.
What do you mean?
Make me suffer.
I'm not watching while I can watch off stream.
It won't be the same.
Oh, shit.
Because we have announcement stream at 3, guys.
A big announcement with Rin, Amelie, and Aramouse.
I have to be at 2.30 so we can prep.
for it.
It's supposed...
Oh!
Keep playing, keep playing!
Look, see, he can walk!
He was just cracked!
Oh!
Oh, it's quarter.
I had everything's unscheduled for it.
I...
I have to be at 2.30 to, like, prep everything for it.
Because, uh, Mousy and I are hosting the announcement so i
need to make sure we have everything prepped up and then
like debrief and stuff and like everything is like scheduled
so like i can't delay it if i could i would if i could and
also because like rin it's gonna be really late for rin so
like we don't want to like make her stay up for too long too
because it was very hard coordinating all for this because
uh because uh uh we're all in different time zones mousy
works at jst time i well emily and i work at pst and then uh
rin works at obviously eu time so so it was like hard to
like this was like the only time slot that works for all
four of us
yeah because like the nas was supposed to be like yesterday
uh but then mousy he got sick, so we have to reschedule it.
I hope she's still, I hope she's still, like, under the
weather, so I hope she'll be okay for it.
It was just unfortunate.
It was, like, on the day of the finals.
Cucurella, why don't you use the hair?
You weren't...
You didn't carry it earlier.
Oh, shit.
Free ball.
Yeah, it's about we're revealing uh the why we were in korea
in an hour and 20 minutes delay the announcement i can't i
can't delay it i if i could i would but it's not on me it's
like all four of the girls like all three of the other girls
plus everything is scheduled so like it's not i can't hold
people up for it even if i want even if i want i guys i know
i can't be selfish there's like oh oh that would have been
crazy shot yeah
that was what a good setup too
sorry girls there's football to watch sister do you a super
chat thank you thank you If I could, if it was just me, if
the announcement was just me, I would delay it.
But like I said, like, this is like a group thing.
So it would be very selfish of me to delay it for the other
girls.
Especially when I have to be there like 30 minutes early so
we could do a debrief and like make sure we're all like,
make sure we're all in the same, on the same page.
Yeah, they keep fucking up their quick time events.
I wonder if there's a closing ceremony of the closing
ceremony.
That sucks.
I would love to watch them carry the trophy out, too.
Love you.
Say love.
Oh, the double closing.
My hydration.
I'm going to get more water, guys.
I'll be right back.
I'm back.
Yeah, like...
i felt bad too because i only want to meet an hour before
the stream to like talk over everything but i was like i
can't because i know it's like an hour i would definitely
miss everything so i was just like i i i can't i do 30
minutes because that was just me that was me being selfish
be like we can meet up like 30 minutes before
nice i got back for the hydration from the hydration break
it's like 3d 3d effects l thank you for this
yeah it's like it's in 3d oh thank you for the super chat
thank you thank you
oh they have give the argentina goliya pay raise his back
must have from carrying his team The Argentina goalkeeper is
insane.
Even Super Chat said you think, thank you.
Like, I don't...
Guys, have they shot the Spanish goalkeeper at all yet?
Have they...
I feel like I haven't seen...
I haven't seen the goalie from Spain, like, just do
anything.
He's...
He's just chilling.
He's having good time.
He's like, I don't know hydration break.
Okay, last 20 minutes, guys.
I believe.
I believe in a 20-minute dream.
Wait, it starts now.
Wait, is the 20 minutes start now?
Wait, no, it doesn't.
We need to wait 10 more, 10 more minutes.
Guys, please.
Guys.
Guys, at this point, please.
I just won't watch.
I won't be able to watch the...
Please.
I'm in the negotiation stage right now.
Oh, oh, that's...
Oh, both...
That was sad on both sides.
Good pass.
Okay.
Oh, shit.
He's alting.
He's getting ready to...
Stage three bargaining.
Please.
I won't watch to the end.
Liz Liz Oh my god This is the first time Does the Spain
goalkeeper remember how to down block Oh never mind he
doesn't have to
Guys it was plus What did he miss?
Oh my god I was so mad I chomped down my Cops drop and I
broke it Totally I actually went And then my Cops drop
fucking broken half.
Guys, if it's plus 30 minutes, I won't be here.
Guys, I won't be here.
Oh, did you guys hear the crunch of it?
You hear my cough drop, break it half?
Yeah, that's how mad I was.
oh my god oh shit that guy's that guy's to say it
oh they're subbing in
do something come on i'm gonna grab a stick
like i don't care which team anymore just sub one of the
teams do something like please at this point
anything come on come on do something come on any of you too
just anything come on I have my life outside of this I have
obligations
What the fuck am I All right Cucarella Mulchies Cucarella Oh
good pass Good pass guys
Roderie Cucarella Ymell, Roderie, Ymell, Cuccarella,
Veritoris, Ymell, Cuccarella, Roderie, I know why are you
passing it to the goalkeeper?
Roderie, Fernandez, oh, oh, shit.
It's so loud, yeah, the ball, that was a crazy shot, though.
Nice.
Corner kick.
Come on.
Come on, Spain.
Do something.
Come on.
Oh my god, what is it?
Come on!
You got on!
Just use it!
I'd better just start killing people in the last 10 minutes.
Oh my god, Spain!
All right.
Man, that's your turn.
Do something.
Use your own.
Come on.
That's it.
Oh my god.
Whose side is this?
Argentina's side.
Yeah.
Do something.
Come on.
Stop edging.
Like I don't care anymore.
Like either of you two.
Someone, any one of them Truly a World Cup final for the
ages
I haven't watched the final in a long time Our finals always
like this I wish I wish I could watch If it does Like if I
could stay I don't mind If it draws out this long The fact
that I couldn't Watch the penalty I can't even watch the
penalties.
Also, it's like...
Penalties are such a gamble.
Is this a...
Is this considered a boring game, guys?
Because...
By God.
Yeah.
Is this...
Would this be considered...
Because I don't watch a lot of World Cup.
Like, our finals.
It's somewhat...
Yeah?
I mean, to be fair, like, I don't think Argentina has shot
one goal.
I don't think the Spanish goalkeeper has done anything.
Oh, good pass.
Stop passing.
Stop.
I know you love passing, but you gotta shoot at one point.
Like, you gotta shoot at one.
What the fuck?
What?
How did he just what is he like what I got?
What happened to the guy?
What's going?
Did he got distract?
Oh, oh, that's what happened.
Oh, my God.
Oh, damn.
Oh, that's oh.
I was just like, he's like gripping his hair.
It's like.
My hair!
Oh!
Ah, damn.
Sam, Spain.
Now, you didn't even get a card for that.
That's insane.
That, that, that looks like it.
It's fucking hurt.
All right, Spain.
Come on, Spain.
Come on.
Back to Cucarella.
And then back to that guy.
And then, and then back to Cucarilla?
And then,
oh, you thought you could.
Is that?
No call.
He's like, no call.
Oh.
Oh, because he reacted.
Oh, that's crazy.
This is the most yellow cards I think I've seen.
Argentina got.
Oh, my.
my god it's because he like reacted to it the rep is all day
the rep has all guys the little dude did he know the rep had
ultimate the rep why is it just why is it only the rep all
day the rep was like yeah buddy yeah buddy don't you do it
don't you don't Don't get cocky now.
The ref is stealing the up.
Yeah, the ref had bad ping.
Guys, they're saving alt for the next four years.
Where is it in?
It's in Morocco, right?
It's in three different countries, I remember.
It's like Morocco, Spain, and what?
Oh!
Keep going.
No call.
Okay, I will see.
I think the ref has like the most endurance and stamina
Because he has to like run back and forth Oh
He's fouling everybody though I think he's making enemies
for both countries right now Or Portugal Yeah it's Morocco
Spain and Portugal Yeah They're saving it for that Spain is
saving their all for their home turf
Oh corner Oh no corner
Is Messi playing anymore?
I feel like I...
I just like...
It's Messi.
I just like he's just there.
I was just like...
Is Messi even on the field?
Or did he just...
I'm like wondering...
He just like...
Go take a break.
He's just like...
I'm gonna go take a hydration break, guys.
He's just vibing.
I feel like...
I was just like, I feel like, yeah, that's what I'm saying.
I know he's the striker.
That's why he's like, is Messi even like around?
At this point, he could take a water break right now.
Yeah, Messi's just like, when is it my turn?
He's like, I don't guess.
I think Mbappe is getting the gold.
Golden foot or whatever it's called.
I don't think Messi is scoring those two goals.
Jesus Christ.
Look at that match momentum.
Oh my God.
All right, for those who don't see it, look at this match
momentum.
That's crazy.
That's actually a little sad.
This was the match momentum.
Oh.
Like...
It's just...
RGT has nine fouls compared with Spain's.
Like they had... Oh my god.
Just... Come on!
I have 25 minutes left!
Come on!
I have I only have 25 minutes.
Please.
Want any of you.
Any of you two.
One goal.
That's all I ask.
Just.
You have like 10 minutes left to all.
Guys.
I know you want to all drink when you're at home turf.
But still.
You have four years to rebuild all.
But nothing ever happens.
Come on, do something!
Oh my god, I fall!
Don't make me...
Oh my god, don't bring me the overtime.
I swear to God, they make it the penalties.
I swear to fucking God.
They make it the penalties and they can't even watch it.
I don't!
All right.
Oh, it's a coroner, or they saved it.
They saved it.
All right, come on.
All right, Cucurada's got it in it.
I don't think they have subs anymore.
They sub like 80 players, though.
They're going to start grabbing people from the crowd.
Oh.
You get it.
I'm going to hold soon if they don't hold.
I'm going to start ulting.
They just passed so much That they fucking forgot how to
shoot Four minutes?
Four minutes What was that?
What the fuck?
Even they're just like hugging it out Please not alt the
players I said alt the ball Stop alting the players Spain
Why are you You all take the players!
Save them for the ball!
Kick ball into goal, not ball, not kick player!
Same with you, same with you, but then...
Oh my god, this...
Oh, same with you, though.
Same with you.
Didn't pick a side, so this is her dessert punishment.
thank you for the super chat thank you thank you oh my god
it's the first time i saw messy in 20 years i i almost
forgot he was there i bro he's finally oh my god they
fucking he slammed into a wall
oh bro just slammed into a drove into a fucking wall oh my
god oh my god this is it this is it he's they're all saying
He said, this is it.
This is it.
They're going to all.
They killed him.
Messia appears and then fucking dies.
That's great.
Oh, my God.
Come on.
The Spanish goalie doesn't even remember how to play the
fucking game.
It's been so long.
Oh, my.
Okay.
Yeah, oh, all right.
He actually still remembered how to play.
Oh, my God.
This is it.
Oh, oh, my God.
That's insane.
Yeah, both.
Woohoo!
Holy shit.
It was like that video of the old man.
Fucking the old man.
Oh, my God.
give me that replay oh my god where like on the old man got
pushed up by a bison and then he got flew flew up in the air
oh my god Argentina when I said oh I said not the players oh
my that's amazing he got buffalo yeeted he actually ulted on
him oh my God where
is he alting they're playing with one less player now bro
actually ragdoll that's crazy he
got two yellow cards so now he has a red is it the guy that
pushed someone are they barring it are you gonna bar it
Bye, Fernandez.
Oh, my God.
He got beckoned.
He's going to get beckoned.
Oh.
Oh, he's.
Oh, I think he wants to call for a viral.
Oh.
Yeah, they're all alting.
They're all alting.
Riff.
He's going to use his viral.
Oh my god.
Oh, I want to be selfish right now.
I really, really do.
Riff all tall over the place.
He was trying to mess.
He was trying to call a Cuckoo Rella for saying something
and covering his mouth.
And then he was like, Raph, he covered his mouth and said a
bad word.
There's too many else I've lost track.
I want to be selfish.
Now the game's interesting.
Oh my god.
Why do you guys always ult in the last 10 minutes?
Why do you do this to me?
Like, oh my god, I have to wait.
I have to wait through 90 minutes of fucking slop just to
get this.
God, do the game ending odds.
They might have drawn.
Come on.
Come on, Spain.
Spain.
Come on.
I still have 15 more minutes.
Spain.
Come on.
Spain!
Spain, come on!
I have 15 minutes left!
It's literally handed to you on a silver platter.
Man!
You're not allowed to cross this line.
Just wanted to do something.
something.
Don't make me get the, don't make me get the slipper.
Oh my god, please.
Please just start the game.
Oh, what a wonderful save.
That, what a great, bro.
It's just, bro, I don't even think any of the other players
are playing.
It's literally just... It's like Spain versus the
goalkeeper.
It's...
Spain versus the goalkeeper.
Ah!
Okay, okay.
Let me negotiate.
Um...
Uh...
Yes.
Is it okay if I delay the stream?
20 minutes I'm stuck in World Cup purgatory and it's the
finals I know it's really selfish to ask but Argentina and
Spain are playing are edging right now and they went over
time
they didn't score a single goal
i'll let them wait okay okay okay i can be i okay the girl
says okay but Oh, I know.
I'll let them, I'm going to let them know.
I can say, I gotta be selfish.
Shout out to Amelie, Rin, and Iron Mouse.
I, I, oh my God, I feel so bad.
I, oh
my God, I can say, I can say, I can say.
They let me, I have to, uh,
All right.
There you go.
Oh.
All right.
I can, I can, I can base.
What, what, how do I do this time?
I don't know.
What is it?
One hour and what?
One hour and 30.
Okay.
All right.
The most by any keeper.
All right, here we go.
It's true.
Watch it, we're all in my room.
The streaming game live.
Such a chill vibe.
All right, even super chat.
Thank you.
Like, huge shout out.
They let me be selfish.
I was just like, I didn't want to, but like...
Spain!
Also, you, Argentina.
You don't think I didn't forget you.
Don't think I didn't forget you.
I set off the goal, not the players.
Don't think I forgot you, Argentina.
Fade!
You could have been like 800 goals already.
The Pokemon continue to sell the score, Bruce.
You're right.
I'm getting it.
What is it called?
Is this?
I'm grabbing it.
That's it.
it that's it they want to see a real alt oh I'll give them a
real alt I'll give
them a real alt wait what is it called
Oh my god
No, it's Miku color too
I'm spade
We're all suffering here.
I'm ulting.
I got it.
Oh my god.
Mike, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
John Slotio.
Oh my god.
No.
Oh, Doki.
16 attempts I got.
Holy shit.
Wait, look at these.
That's crazy.
Oh, those stats are fucking crazy.
All right.
Look at these stats.
Oh, wait.
It's flipped.
Sorry.
A zero.
Zero attempts at the goal.
What else?
I just kissed my sandals.
That's...
Oh my god.
Versus zero.
That's insane.
I saw it even toe to toe.
It's like...
Zero attempts at the goal.
But all four.
fouls oh it's too far
come on come on Spain they had zero attempts at the goal
you've how many shot oh my oh yes yes oh
thank you
false alarm
What's...
Oh my god.
VAR it!
I VAR it!
Alright, let me see the replay.
I don't think that that nobody like like both sides hate the
ref right now
They're gonna like both both countries hate this ref Not
just these two countries
Like why can't they just bar it just bar it oh just bar it
That ref cannot what country is that ref from Where is he
from?
He can't go back.
He can't visit those.
He can never visit Spain or Argentina ever again.
Slovak.
He's from England.
He's never coming back.
Oh, what a fucking steal.
Okay, that steal is crazy.
Is Messi still alive?
Is he?
Oh, there he is.
There he is.
Does Messi still exist in this game?
I can't tell anymore.
I know he's just like, oh, job done.
I did my job.
Wow!
Oh my god.
A foul on Messi.
Oh, why did he cover his balls?
Okay, there's the foul.
There it is.
How?
He grabbed on him.
Are you...
I'm the Spanish player.
I...
Oh, did he step on his foot?
Oh, okay.
Oh, my God.
Five minutes left.
He passed the ball through the ref's legs.
Do you see that?
Oh, did he step on him?
Yeah, guys, I don't look at the feet, guys.
Yes, I'm not a feet person.
It's called football.
How many subs are there?
Probably ain't dad over.
Like this.
He's watching this game with me.
He's watching this game.
He is stopping with me.
Oh
Get to watch
You didn't expect this did you huh?
There's it's literally a 10 v 11
That was close that was close That was actually a really
close shot.
What are you looking at me for?
Huh?
What are you looking at me?
Why are you looking at me?
Look at the fucking TV
Oh, if it was just a bad head, that's right, you're, you
have bad head.
Got to practice more.
Yeah, he's just like, I just want a treat.
Oh my god, come on.
Come on.
Anything.
Yes and no.
Oh my god.
Messy's playing!
Messy!
Oh my god, there's gonna be a riot.
There's actually gonna be a riot.
Big thing in the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh my god.
They're gonna start running.
They're gonna start running into the field.
Oh!
Oh shit!
Oh my god!
And then they're gonna start fighting.
Oh my god, the coach is going to start fucking fighting.
Yeah, people sound really, really mad.
Oh,
wait, the coach got carded.
Wait, did he really?
Oh, shit.
Oh, my god.
but holy shit the coach got carded that's crazy and what do
you do when the coach gets carded and you leave like what
happens like what if he gets a red card what happens like
did they remove a player from the field so of course the
only way to end this madness is to take you with for chat
thank you thank you wait wait no but do they do they remove
a player on the field as well or just the coach like do they
like do they remove the coach and the player oh he is bad
that's crazy i've never seen a coach get card why did he get
caught oh he must have like yelled at the ref and the ref
was like, I ain't fucking around.
Oh, the ref is from Slovenia?
He's not allowed in Spain or Argentina again.
He's pissed off both Spain and Argentina.
Is the ref gonna get guided?
The var ref comes out and cards the ref.
Imagine a var ref comes out and be like, gives the ref a
yellow card.
Oh, Oh my God, people are at, I, but when do the, when do
the play, when do the, the fans start running into, what?
For at least his coach is a fast way to get bad from the
game.
Patrick Rester, thank you.
Thank you.
He uno reverse.
Yeah, he brings out the uno reverse card.
Oh, oh.
All right, 30 seconds till the second.
half
oh shit
all right final whistle all right 100 minutes i'll be an
hour 45
oh my god i'm so you and you you you you like i don't know
anymore for you you you you're playing something else you're
not you're you're in a different game but you too You, you
two, I, you, you, how do you miss every shot you take?
You, how can you put us through more hell?
I don't know.
Yeah, like, you're just, you're playing the different sport
right now.
I can't even say what, I can't even say anything about it.
But you two, you two.
Yeah, this is murder ball.
It's because of the halftime show.
I blame the fucking halftime show.
Or can't you see?
I mean, like, bro, did you not see the stats, guys?
Like, what can I say?
And there's like, like, what can I say about this?
Oh, sorry, it's flipped.
But, like, what can I say about this?
this like like and like there's nothing I can say like
you like I would disappointed these two the most this is
that so many opportunities to end this
that's uh it's 19 the zero like i at some points i don't
even know if the spades goalkeeper is alive are they are
they even alive or do they do they do they exist like
um oh yeah Yes!
Oh my god!
Oh god!
Oh Doki, dad woke up.
He woke up.
He's like, what happened?
Oh!
It's so big.
It's so...
Oh.
It's...
Oh my god.
It finally happened.
Alright, get out.
Oh, get out.
Dad.
Get out.
Okay.
Alright.
Oh my god.
Oh, that's beautiful.
That was beautiful.
That.
That was a.
Oh, that was a beautiful shot too.
Wow.
Oh my god, give me that replay again.
Give me that replay.
Oh, I know it's so beautiful.
Oh my god, he fucking broke the pole.
Holy shit.
All right.
Oh.
Oh, finally.
Oh, my God.
Oh, shit.
The timer.
What's the timer?
I never started a timer.
I...
What's the time?
I've lost track.
What even is the time?
Okay, I assume it's this.
I don't even know.
I think it's this.
Yeah, but I'm on an hour clock.
What is it on the hour clock?
I don't have a minute clock, guys.
All right, is it 40?
It's 50.
Is it this?
Is this correct?
Is this close enough?
Over by a minute.
it all right
i'll fix it i'm just i'm done i'm already checked out
i'm already i'm i'm i'm good to go i that i waited they
finally altered he finally altered i'm
oh my god they finally thought i waited this long for the
all they finally did it i waited 80 years to see it happen
oh i no longer care
Jesus Christ Does Spain have a yellow?
I don't even think Spain has it I told you guys I told you
the Miku curse The Miku curse is real I told you guys Oh we
can delay the stream Oh I need to adjust the waiting room
Real right now I'm gonna adjust it We're pushing the stream
back Um Um Here you go.
Oh.
Oh my god.
Cucarella.
Rodry.
Pedry.
Williams.
Cucarella.
Pedry.
Yeah!
At this rate, I'll let them have it.
Holy shit, what a fucking...
Like, he's just like, Whoa!
Offside.
How much longer?
I think we have, what, eight minutes, right?
Maybe 10 minutes of extra time.
700 passes?
Oh!
Offside.
That was...
Where was it?
Oh, he was literally just...
That's insane.
That was a crazy...
Crazy goal, too.
Oh, John, oh, you're a little too late.
You're a little too late there.
Oh, Jesus.
Oh, thank you, the super chat.
Thank you.
He goes offside.
He was in front of the other defender.
Six minutes.
Wait, Messi can play now.
Messi can play.
Argentina using Baccholos gets to...
make it to a whole man think of a super chat think oh never
mind got get baited messy get fucking baited but i feel bad
for the argentina goalkeeper like i swear it's just spain
versus the goalkeeper like i don't know what the other
players are doing
oh my god messy gets to play messy gets to play oh messy no
play messy no play oh
my god wait wait Oh, guys, two shots at the goal.
Two attempts at the goal, guys.
It's no longer zero.
Guys, it's no longer zero.
Oh, my God.
It's no longer.
Let them play or kill.
The record read.
No longer double in seven.
Oh my god.
Oh, a corner.
That has to be a corner.
Five minutes left.
You guys are just taking that shot.
Oh, oh, he fucked up the dribble.
What a, what, oh my god.
What the fuck was that dribble?
Yeah, he fumbled the dribble.
There was nobody pressuring him.
is a plus two minutes I think
oh oh my god oh oh my god is he okay that's actually oh oh
my god wait bro he's like shaking oh oh
oh scott stir like headshot that's oh my god bro okay Okay,
does he have a concussion?
He gave him the Scott Sterling special.
Oh my god, the arm.
Are you serious?
That's...
That was the offside.
I think, like, I don't know.
Sometimes I feel like it's a little too picky, you know?
The offside rule.
It's a little too specific.
More stalling.
Bro, who was the guy that got the red card?
He's so fucked.
He's not allowed back to Argentina.
They lose this.
Because it's not over until the...
Oh.
That is a foul.
No yellow card, though, but it's a foul.
That guy's not allowed back to Argentina.
Yeah, Fernandez, he's fucked.
He's so fucked.
I don't think that he's allowed to be like on the plane I
don't yeah I think it's like three minutes left
he had a ban for racism holy shit what
oh that was close that was so close that goalkeeper didn't
even know what the fuck happened the the uh spain's
goalkeeper was just like what happened like he was not
defending that that was insane save yeah the spanish holy
shit they're wrestling they started wrestling they're
wrestling right now
oh five minutes five minutes where's the ball where's the I
don't even see the ball anymore.
I was like, what happened?
Where did the ball go?
Oh, please.
Oh.
Oh, my God.
Holy shit.
This is actually a brawl right now.
They're like brawling on the field.
Oh, too high.
It's getting real here.
oh they have five that four minutes they still so much time
you know this is a lot better than the first 80 percent of
this game of zero zero attempts at the goal they're actually
at the goal now the spain the spain goalkeeper has to play
he's got back from his bathroom break
no foul no get up get up there's no foul get the up you know
acting over
what no foul no oh yes foul the argentina goalkeeper should
be legally allowed to kill his he is like the one in england
one too he should be he should be legally allowed to kill
Fernandez.
Another foul?
What do you do?
Wait, what?
Oh, that's the goal shot.
I was like, that?
There's no foul there.
Two minutes.
Volleyball.
They're, like, playing volleyball now.
Oh.
Foul?
Foul on...
Another one?
Bro, Spade, stop fucking getting fouled, bro!
Oh, nice pass.
Good pass.
Minute and 30.
He's gotta take his time now.
40 seconds.
Oh, Cucarella!
Last attempt.
This is Cucarella.
Spade, RGTSB.
Final push.
20 seconds.
Oh, Mulder's so mad.
Oh, Spain's so mad.
Oh, my God.
The goalkeeper's taking the foul shot.
Oh,
and Spain takes it.
The curse was real.
The Miku curse was real.
Nope.
I was the first one that said it.
The Miku curse takes another.
Her last victim.
I told you.
The Miku curse.
Let's go.
It's Miku tab.
It's Miku, Miku.
Na na na na na na na na.
Oh, but he's just like...
Miku?
That's not good.
The Miku curse lies with Spain now.
Miku's last victim.
Miku takes one last victim.
Oh my god No one has Miku for more than one game I told you
No one No one has No one has Miku For more than one game
That one guy That one guy cannot go home right now
Oh my god card actually killed them that guy could not keep
his temper if he didn't push that one guy um if he didn't
push that one guy it would have been fine he literally
fucked over his team because he pushed him
yeah he was if he didn't if holy shit what the what oh
did you guys see
that oh he started beating
up was like throwing fists at like yeah there was a mind the
mosh pit in the Oh my god It's Royal Rump Yeah Like there
was like Like a bunch of Spain And Argentina players started
Moshing in the middle Yeah they were brawling
That's crazy Alright guys I wish I could watch more But I
have to go to the announcement now But Thank you guys for
being here On my journey On my art guys i would love to see
them get crowned uh get like hold the trophy and everything
but i have to go now um but thank you guys for watching
thank you all for being here for the last finals the i'll be
rating the i'll be rating the announcement stream but thank
you everybody for joining me on my football art um this is
the first thing the first time trying doing this type of
these types of streams so i'm glad you all enjoyed uh
watching a lot with me watching me And everything and it's
been really fun.
I had a really fun time watching this with you guys and It
was crazy crazy like okay It was only crazy during the last
15 minutes like I will say the last 15 minutes where it got
fucking Last 20 minutes where it got fucking wild not even
20 30 minutes, maybe yeah 30 minutes when they started when
they got the red card It went wild, but thank you guys.
I'll see you guys in in four years.
All right, I'm going to go raid the announcement stream now.
I have to actually go get prepped up right now.
Bye, guys.
Bye.
Thank you all for coming to the World Cup, Art.
Congratulations on Spain for winning.
You won Miku.
Good luck in four years, I guess.
I don't know if the Miku curse can incubate for four years.
I'll see you guys later, everybody.
Bye-bye.